During World War II, Nazi engineers designed
and built a number of revolutionary super
or “wonder weapons” (wunderwaffe), including
a wide array of aircraft, guns and ships.
Among these weapons is a mysterious small,
round tank named the Kugelpanzer (literally
meaning “spherical tank”).
This odd little tank was never seen in the
European theater, and very little is definitively
known about its purpose.
What is known is that it was made in Germany
and shipped to Japan, and then later captured
by the Soviets in 1945, probably in Manchuria.
Today, the only one known to exist can be
found in the Kubinka Tank Museum in the Odintsovsky
District, Moscow Oblast, Russia.
Powered by a single cylinder, two-stroke engine,
Kugelpanzer has a slit in the front (presumably
a driver’s view port), and a small arm and
wheel in the rear (perhaps for stability and/or
maneuvering).
Its hull is only 5 mm (.2 in.)
thick, and it isn’t fully clear what type
of metal comprises its armor (no metal samples
are currently allowed to be taken from it).
Popular theories of its purpose include reconnaissance,
as a mobile observation post for managing
artillery fire, and as a cable-laying vehicle;
however, there is little evidence to support
any of these hypotheses, since there has never
been any documentation found that explains
the vehicle or its design.
Given the dearth of evidence, as you would
expect, speculation is rampant, and one intriguing
theory even posits that it was commissioned
by the Japanese as part of their kamikaze
strategy of suicide missions.
By August 1944, the ailing Japanese military
had been at war in the Pacific for 7 long
years, beginning with the Second Sino-Japanese
War in 1937.
During this period, rather than being captured,
and wanting to get in one last lick, some
Japanese pilots had begun the practice of
crashing their mostly disabled planes into
enemy positions (and killing themselves in
the process).
Through most of the Pacific War, this was
an informal, voluntary act; however, as the
war was winding down, the desperate Japanese
command (who were running out of qualified
pilots and whose aircraft at this point in
the war were outdated) decided that they would
get the most out of their unskilled personnel
and obsolete machinery by incorporating planned
suicide missions into their battle strategies.
As such, in the fall of 1944, Japanese forces
began a series of kamikaze strikes.
(Click here for more on the origin of the
kamikaze and how pilots were chosen for this
duty.)
In addition to improvised devices, such as
simply strapping bombs onto existing aircraft,
the Japanese military began manufacturing
specialized equipment.
These included the aircraft Ohka (“cherry
blossom”), as well as suicide boats, such
as Shinyo (“sea quake”).
Even tiny submarines were made, including
a modified torpedo named Kaiten (“returning
to heaven,”) and Kairyu (“sea dragon”),
a two-manned craft.
Given this mindset of many Japanese military
leaders, it has been theorized by some that
the Kugelpanzer was a part of this plan, with
a few key points often put forth to support
this theory.
First, like all of the other suicide machines,
it was small and designed to be operated with
a limited (1-2 man) crew; second, it wasn’t
equipped with any apparent offensive weaponry,
though it has been speculated that it was
meant to have a machine gun mounted in the
front; and third, its hull was rather flimsy
(5 mm thick) when compared to that of other
armored vehicles, but on par with that of
at least one other suicide craft.
For instance, the Type 97 Chi-Ha, said to
be the “most widely produced Japanese medium
tank of World War II,” had 26 mm thick armor
on the sides of the turret and 33 mm thick
armor on its gun shield.
On the other hand, the Long Lance torpedo
from which the Kaiten manned torpedo was developed
had a comparably thin shell at 3.2 mm (.13
in.)
thick – much closer to the width of the
Kugelpanzer outer housing, than the strong
armor of the Type 97 tank.
For further reference, the thickness of a
common World War II helmet (the M1) was at
.035 to .037 inches (just under 1 mm), sufficient
to (at least sometimes) stop a .45 caliber
bullet.
So, essentially, the 5 mm thick walls of the
tank would have been sturdy enough to relatively
reliably stop many types of enemy bullets
from getting in, but thin enough to give way
easily from a blast within, to do maximum
damage.
At least, so this particularly theory goes.
Whatever its intended use, the Kugelpanzer
certainly has gone down as one of the more
unique weapons developed during WWII.